When the earth shakes, the ground moves and things start to fall,...
...you'll ask yourself, "How prepared or unprepared are you?"
Have you removed objects from over the bed and over your head,...
...anchored your possessions securely to the wall?
It won't be a pain and you're not doing it in vain.
Are your emergency kits packed?
What about your family, your friends?
Do they know what to do,...
...how to get in touch and where to meet?
Do you know how to drop, cover and hold on, covering your head and neck?
What if you're outside or in a car?
After the shaking stops, look around.
Figure out what to do.
Stay away from damaged areas.
Turn on a radio.
Reach out for help,...
...and if you're trapped, do not move about.
Stay calm, only shout as a last resort.
Once everything and everyone is safe, get prepared.
An aftershock could be on its way.
So, before the earth shakes, the ground moves and things start to fall, get prepared,...
...make a plan,...
...practice what you know...
...because an earthquake can happen anytime, anywhere.
You never know.